you
the everyday citizen is interested of
course in statistics however the
classical statistical book is very
complex that's why we need to simplify
to focus in order to make this form of
statistics digestible also for laypeople
the video is part of a communication
package the first publication that we
will produce is the classical
statistical publication with tables and
graphs and maps on sustainable
development a second publication will be
produced which is in the form of a block
and the video is a kind of animation of
this second more late person oriented
publication and we are now issuing a
third publication which is focused on
how to communicate in a proper way with
indicators sustainable development is
composed of dimensions and issues which
are important for you and for me this
virtual character and she is writing a
block and the block is about sustainable
development so you can imagine that M is
interested in creating a block which is
very close to her own interest that her
grandpa is producing organic products
that her friend Marta is interested in
income distributions indeed and story
shows that Eurostat sustainable
development indicators are relevant for
everyday lives of EU citizens it is
connected to sustainable development
it's connected to the long term strategy
and UN level which is the sustainable
development goal prodigy and it is
connected to the application of this in
the EU well it is important to engage
citizens
to let them work with us because we want
citizens to be informed and the best way
is to let them interact with us and let
them become co-producers of statistics
we are using traditional ways
publications web sites graphs whatever
you like and the youngest babies in our
family of communication are the
indicator sets dashboards and videos
blogs tweets which are normally used by
us on a daily basis